i thought it would be interesting to get
a little bit more intuition on ellipses
and their foci or foci sometimes i like
to call them focuses but the correct
word is foci or foci but either
pronunciation is apparently okay so
let's work with this this is an
interactive exercise on khan academy you
see over here so let's see if we can
work through this together and learn a
little bit more about ellipses so they
tell us the equation of an ellipse is x
minus x1 squared over a squared plus y
minus one squared over b squared equals
one and this is true this is the
equation of an ellipse this would be an
ellipse that is centered at x equals x1
y equals y1 the
major radius would be a the minor radius
would be b
so then they say find the foci of the
ellipse below by moving the orange
points to their correct positions
then use that information to find the
values of x1 y1 a and b
so they want us to move these to the
correct position the correct position is
where the sum of the distance so if we
move it to the correct position the the
sum of the the length of that red line
and the length of that green line should
be constant now you can see they're
clearly not in the correct position
right over here because we're up here
when i was moving it around you see that
look the distance to focus 1 from this
point on the ellipse is 11.7 that's the
green line the distance to focus 2 is 6.
you add them together 17.8 but when you
move it around that changes and so we
would have to find
we would have to find a different we
could just keep trying in different foci
until that sum of these the red length
and the greed length is constant now in
my mind that is a hard way to do it an
easier way to do it would be well let's
figure out the center of
the ellipse first which we could do just
literally by inspecting this this
drawing and then figure out what the
length of the major radius and the minor
radius is and then use that information
to find the foci so let's see if i can
put these dots let me put them first at
the center all right so let's see
so
that center and let me
that looks pretty good that looks like
the center
and i can even confirm so in the y
direction that is if i'm at the top of
the ellipse i am 10 from that center and
if i'm at the bottom of the ellipse i'm
from that center and so that does look
like the center and it also tells us it
tells us that the
that the major radius is 10 and it's
along the y-axis so the major radius is
10 and it's along the y-axis
and we also know the y-coordinate of the
center it's y is equal to four
y is equal to four and then the
x-coordinate of the center is x equals
five
so once again where i put this orange
dot that is the center of the ellipse
it's at x equals five
y equals four and that's why i put x
equals five or x one equals five y one
equals four
and you see from the equation of ellipse
that's what defines the center of the
ellipse and then a is going to be
a we can see from here this is the
radius in the x direction i guess you
want me to think about it and that's
going to be the minor radius it's a
shorter radius and you see that has
length 8. we're going from x equals 5 to
x equals 13 or x equals or x equals
negative 3 to x equals 5. so it has
length 8.
so this thing right over here a is going
to be 8.
so this is 8. and we already said the
major radius is going to be in the
vertical direction and it is of length
10.
so just like that we figured out we
could write the equation down i don't
have my pen out but you could just say
this the equation of this ellipse is
going to be x minus 5 squared over
8 squared plus y minus
4 squared over 10 squared equals 1.
but now let's actually figure out where
we need to put these where we need to
actually put these foci and then valid
and then figure out that hey look if we
put them in the right place the sum of
the red and green lines is going to be
is going to be a constant and clearly
where they are right now it's not a
constant you see that sum of the
distances is at 20.6 and then it goes to
20 point it's clearly not constant
so let's see if we can do it and one way
to do it is just remember well there's a
formula and we we talk about it we
explore the intuition behind it in a
previous video but the formula for the
foci ellipse is you find the difference
between the larger of these two values
and the smaller of these two values so
so in this case you would find the
difference between 10 squared and 8
squared well that's going to be 100
minus 64
which is 36 and then you take the square
root of that so it's going to be equal
to 6. so the focal length is going to be
equal to 6. so if we go back to the
center
if you go back to the center
if we figure out our focal length is 6.
and again remember all i did is i took
the larger of these i squared it and
from that i subtracted the other one
squared so 100 squared minus 8 squared
is is 100 minus 64 which is 36 and i
took the square root of that to get 6.
so our focal length and along the major
axis i could say is going to be six so
it's going to be six from the center
up and six from the center down so six
from the center up one two three four
five six and six from the center down
one two three four five six now that's
what the math tells us but let's just
make sure that this actually holds this
actually holds so now let's go to points
on the folk on the ellipse and you see
with it it's calculating the distance to
each of the foci
and those lines or the length of the
lines or the distances and you see when
you sum them up we are at
we are at a nice constant 20 which is
the really cool thing about ellipses
that look i can go anywhere around here
and the sum of these two distances of
the green and the red line their lengths
is a constant 20. that's actually what
defines what defines an ellipse in fact
you can draw an ellipse on a chalkboard
if you have if you could draw this
ellipse on a chalkboard if you had a
string of say length 20 centimeters and
you put one focus there and one focus
there and you kind of put your chalk in
the string and you just tried to move it
around
and so it would look something it would
look something like that anyway
hopefully you found that as as fun as i
did